If Donald Trump could shoot somebody in
the middle of Fifth Avenue and get away with it,
what brazenness might we expect from his fellow billionaire in New York egomaniac, Michael Bloomberg?
The media mogul gave us a glimpse back in 2001, while dumping the first round of 74 million dollars
into his late in life political career, when a reporter covering the New York mayoral race
asked him whether he had ever smoked marijuana.
You bet I did and I enjoyed it, Bloomberg bragged. Talk about do as I say, not as I did.
During Bloomberg's three terms as mayor the Big Apple became the marijuana arrest capital
of the world. Thanks to the notorious stop and frisk searches conducted largely in neighborhoods
where billionaires rarely venture. But Mayor Mike's conscience has never been noticeably troubled
by such obvious disparities under the law. If anything, disproportionately impacting the poor
is a conscious policy choice. In a conversation two years ago Bloomberg defended his fondness
for taxing items such as sugary sodas and trans fats that are mostly enjoyed by the non rich.
Some people say well taxes are regressive but in this case, yes they are, that's the good thing about them,
because the problem is in people that don't have a lot of money. And so higher taxes we should have a bigger
impact on their behavior and how they deal with themselves. The question is do you want to pander to
those people or do you want to get them to live longer. Rules may be important for those people,
because the problem is in people that don't have a lot of money. And so higher taxes we should have a bigger
of gun control advocacy in America, and one of the few people allowed to have an armed security detail
when traveling in Bermuda. He has been positively Trumpian about releasing his tax returns over the years,
snapping at the mere suggestion that such political traditions should apply to him.
And as recently as January 2019, even as the rest of the Democratic Party was finally evolving toward
ending federal prohibitions on the marijuana Bloomberg once enjoyed, he called pot legalization
perhaps the stupidest thing we've ever
done if George W Bush and Barack Obama
assured in the return of the imperial
presidency Trump and potentially
Bloomberg represents a further
And as recently as January 2019, even as the rest of the Democratic Party was finally evolving toward
phone and I can use that pen to sign
executive orders and take executive
action there was an audacity in Obama's
pen and phone and there was a whole
theory of executive branch autonomy
dreamed up by former Vice President Dick
Cheney Trump's contribution has been
more vulgar more direct more New York
he's walking out like big high fives
smiling laughing like to punch him in
the face I'll tell you
Bloomberg's manners may be more refined
but only a little
there's the locker room talk about women
which she has already preemptively
apologized for Trump may troll people
about seeking a third term but Bloomberg
actually went there changing New York
City law near the end of his term
limited second term in order to run for
a third and then switching the law back
soon after winning as the New York Times
noted at the time
Bloomberg thinks that being able to
serve three terms in office is a good
idea just not for anyone else
Mike's above the law demeanor might seem
preferable to Donald's base appetite for
corruption but their approaches to how
rules apply to mere mortals are
distressingly similar to Trump
constitutional limits on executive power
are speed bumps slowing down as policy
goals especially concerning immigration
to Bloomberg policy ends justify even
unconstitutional means before very
recently changing his mind on stop and
frisk the former mayor defended it as he
did the New York Times in September 2018
like this I think people the voters want
low crime they don't want kids to kill
each other it seems unlikely that in an
era of resurgent democratic populism
primary voters will reward the kind of
moneybags who has literally appeared in
skits as King Michael
but seeing Bloomberg even in fourth
place continues an alarming trend we've
stacked up so much power at 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue that billionaires
with insatiable ambitions are eyeing
that address greedily and finding market
share among understandably disgruntled
voters lawyer Alan Dershowitz said on
Fox News last year that the president
has the power that Kings have never had
until we start consciously limiting that
power we will continue getting the
Royals we deserve
you